magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman welcome
everybody hope you had a good weekend a
lot of different things going on and i
want to jump right into it you know one
of the things that was good last week
that happened on the one year
anniversary of the january sixth trump
riots was that at least in some circles
there was a message which we heard
multiple times which is okay it's been a
year
and a year ago it didn't work the
insurrection failed the attempt at a
coup
failed to actually keep the guy who
didn't win in power
but instead of saying great it failed we
don't need to think about it anymore
many prominent voices have been saying
the coup attempt continues they're going
to go crazy in 2024 trying to do it
again and they may even try it to some
degree in 2022 and unless we're prepared
it has been made clear
that were they slightly less incompetent
they might have pulled it off still
unlikely they truly would have pulled it
off but the major and basic systems of
democracy that we in some sense take for
granted could have failed us and there
are a bunch of different pieces that i
want to mention to you today that have
been published which i think are really
really good and step back for a second
and think about from how many different
areas we are hearing this
former military generals
former u.s presidents
uh some of the most quoted thinkers of
our time like noam chomsky and on and on
and on so let's just jump right in and
take a look now last week we already
looked at this first example
retired general warns the u.s military
could back a coup after the 2024
election i i have an entire clip on this
on the youtube channel so i won't redo
it but the gist of this was that
actually three retired generals are
warning
that if in 2024 we saw
another desire
and another attempt for republicans to
take an election that they did not win
if
they had the support
of the upper echelon of the military if
the upper echelon of the military
believed
that the person that won didn't actually
win and decided to help the
insurrectionists the outcome could be
completely different in other words that
the coup could succeed
if the insurrectionists had the upper
echelon of the military on their side we
talked about that last week
also last week we started we we are
starting to see concern in canada our
friendly neighbors to the north of if
the us is no longer democratic what does
that mean for us how do we need to
protect ourselves and i told you about
this report and article from the
canadian political science professor
thomas homer dixon who is saying we in
canada this is not even a warning to
americans this is thomas homer dixon
warning his own country and saying
we could have a right-wing dictatorship
in the united states by 2030. depending
on what happens in 22 and in 24 and
theoretically subsequently in 2028
with a continued erosion
of
a continued growth of this authoritarian
right-wing movement
um bolstered to some degree by the way
by some left-wingers looking away and
saying there's nothing to see here that
that's also part of the problem but
mostly the people doing it are the
problem
the u.s could be a right-wing
dictatorship by 2030. but there are more
concerns and i think it's great that
this is being published from different
voices
because it is so important to understand
jimmy carter wrote a really good piece
last week on the eve of the january 6
trump riot anniversary in the new york
times called i fear for our democracy
and
this is part of a number of essays that
were published and it's very very much
worth reading
but in it jimmy carter says one year on
promoters of the lie that the election
was stolen have taken over one political
party and stoked distrust in our
electoral systems these forces exert
power and influence through relentless
disinformation which continues to turn
americans against americans according to
the survey center on american life 36
percent of americans agree that the
traditional american way of life is
disappearing so fast that we may have to
use force to save it
the washington post recently reported
roughly 40 percent of republicans
believe violent action against the
government is sometimes justified and in
this
in this jimmy carter says they seek to
win by any means and many americans are
being persuaded to think and act
likewise threatening to collapse the
foundations of our security and
democracy with breathtaking speed i now
fear that what we have fought so hard to
achieve globally
the right to free fair elections
unhindered by strongmen politicians who
seek nothing more than to grow their own
power has become dangerously fragile at
home good for jimmy carter noam chomsky
noam chomsky says the republican soft
coup
is still underway
one year after the capital assault and
this includes transcripts of an
interview
uh with um with chomsky where he says
participants in the assault on the
capital doubtless had varying
perceptions and motives but were united
in the effort to overthrow an elected
government in short an attempted coup by
definition
it was furthermore an attempt that could
have succeeded if a few prominent
republican figures had changed their
stance and gone along with the coup
attempt and if the military command had
made different decisions
chomsky referencing what the retired
generals say if you get the military the
outcome can be different
trump was making every effort to
facilitate the coup which would surely
have been applauded by a large majority
of republican voters and by the
republican political leadership with
which with few exceptions grovels at his
feet in a shameful display of cowardice
implications for the future are all too
clear the republican organization is
carefully laying the groundwork for
success next time
whatever the electoral outcome might be
um
this is
very very serious and lastly
jim crisinger with a good piece opinion
what authoritarianism would look like in
america where he writes
many americans don't fear a potential
slide into authoritarianism because they
have no basis for doing so our oceans
and hegemony have coddled us we take
democracy for granted but democracy and
the rule of law are not the normal state
of governments certainly not
historically pointing out
authoritarianism wouldn't happen
overnight
but authoritarian regimes have shown us
a roadmap if trump and his enablers get
their way
how you experience your life would
depend on whether you identified and
were identified as a trump republican
identified as a trump republican with
your bumper sticker you'd be more likely
to get a warning instead of a speeding
ticket you'd gain the inside track for
government jobs grants and permits
decisions about government benefits like
unemployment and disability would be
more likely to go your way your children
would be more likely to win scholarships
and admission to their chosen schools
you'd get more favorable loan and
mortgage treatment better access to
scarce goods the best tickets
regulations would be interpreted in your
favor or maybe just ignored you could
rely on the criminal justice and
judicial systems to go easy on you if
not help you out this is a very very
much worth reading article
and there are a lot of people already
saying the 2024 election is going to be
bonkers nuts you are going to see them
put up claims of fraud just like they
did in 2020 but they may have
secretaries of state election
administrators actually willing to do
the flip remember in georgia brad
raffensberger said we're not going to do
that we're not going to do that
they may actually lay the groundwork
where they do have secretaries of state
willing to play ball and i don't think
we're going to have to wait until 2024
to see it i believe the midterms are
going to show us where we are headed and
how quickly and so there's a lot of
people in the right-wing media who
dismiss january 6th because it failed
and you would better believe that if
they had succeeded
and trump was still president some of
those very people saying it wasn't
really anything because it failed would
be praising it
as a victory for the real winner so
those people you can't listen to they
don't care about democracy
they're against it if democracy leads to
an outcome they don't want it's not been
a priority of the republican party for a
really long time and unfortunately there
is now a whole series of clones of
donald trump that are out there in
congress and running for office in 2022
and no doubt in 2024. so good for all of
these people continuing to point out
this is not over it's not they tried it
once and it failed and now we move on
they're going to try it again
now i want to talk about something else
that is is very very important because
in light of
the concerns about future
authoritarianism saying hey you know
what in an authoritarian u.s you would
start to see for example
the trumpists will get lighter sentences
or better treatment from the judicial
system
this is already sort of happening and
i'm going to give you guys some very
specific examples there's this context
we've seen about the trump rioters now
more than 700 of them who have been
charged that they're being treated so
unfairly that they're being held in bad
conditions in jail in prison pre-trial
detention all of these different things
and we actually now have an
investigation as to the sentences for
these individuals and it turns out that
two-thirds of the sentences for the
trump writers
are milder than what the prosecution has
recommended judges are getting the
recommendation and they're saying i'm
going to give them a lighter sentence in
two-thirds of the times now if you look
at individual sentences
you'll see right winger saying four
years for this
five years for that that's crazy they're
being treated poorly because they're
trumpists but let's look at the actual
data
judges have declined u.s proposed
sentences
in two thirds of the january sixth cases
so far these this is among those who
have been sentenced
um
when federal this is the washington post
when federal judges in washington began
hearing guilty pleas from some of the
hundreds of riot participants from the
riots some were highly critical of
prosecutors for pursuing only
misdemeanor charges and not just seeking
jail time for many defendants
is it the government's view that the
members of the mob that engaged in the
capital attack were simply trespassers
asked district judge beryl howell
incredulously in october
is general deterrence going to be served
by letting rioters who broke into the
capitol over ran police resolve
liability through petty offense please
but for all four defendants howell
sentenced she has imposed less jail time
than prosecutors sought
saying that government plea deals in
most misdemeanor cases are forcing
judges to choose whether short jail
terms or years of probation pose a
stronger deterrent her decisions are not
unusual the article goes on to say
federal judges in dc have gone below the
government recommendation in 49 of 74
sentencings held for the rioters in the
year since the attack that's about
two-thirds of the cases most have not
yet been sentenced so we're looking at
the ones that have
in eight cases were prosecutors asked
for jail time the judges opted for
probation
of the 74 people sentenced so far 35
have been given jail or prison time
14 home detention and 25 probation alone
there is a
sort of infographic here that you can
look at and we'll link to this which
shows
uh in pink those who got lighter
sentences than the recommended
in yellow those who got harsher and that
applies to looks like a couple
and those who got exactly what was
recommended
um it is untrue it is untrue that the
trump rioters are being treated unfairly
harshly now we're going to get to some
of these other aspects later which
include you know republicans saying well
it's just terrible how they're being
held in pre-trial detention they can't
build a good defense if that's what you
do yes people like me have been saying
for decades pre-trial detention
which is disproportionately something
for people that can't afford bail in
some case sometimes it's because you
can't afford bail sometimes it's not
granted different situations we've been
saying that needs to be reformed for a
really really long time the right never
cared now they care because it's
trumpists those same right-wingers
saying these people are being treated
like terrorists now some say they are
terrorists but the conditions in these
jails are terrible one guy didn't even
get the vegan food that he asked for
we've been talking about jail and prison
conditions in the united states for
decades they didn't care they used to
say well
if you're there you're there for a
reason and you don't deserve to be in a
norwegian hotel or what you know
whatever analogy they like to make now
they care because it's quote their
people so let's look at the facts
two-thirds getting lighter sentences
than what was recommended
make sure you're following me on twitter
at deepakman remember that tomorrow
tuesday january 11th 6 pm eastern we
will be doing the first david pakman
show chess tournament of the year make
sure you join our chess club it's free
this is totally free
davidpakman.com chess and then you can
play in the tournament tomorrow i hope
to see you
then it is a brand new year maybe you
have goals around getting in better
shape maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our
longtime sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto
or if like me you just try to limit your
sugar intake you can build your own
variety pack with flavors like cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cinnamon
cookies and cream waffle maple blueberry
that's my favorite magic spoon lets you
enjoy a sweet delicious snack without
the guilt you can stick to your goals
and still treat yourself and if you
don't love magic spoon as much as i do
they'll give you all of your money back
no questions asked magic spoon is giving
my audience five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman
welcome back everybody remember that the
david pakman show is primarily funded by
viewers and listeners through the
membership program that's particularly
true for the next 90 days as we have
been banned
from all monetization on facebook why
because an algorithm misinterpreted
a pro-vaccine video
that we posted as anti-vaccine i'll have
more information about that tomorrow but
needless to say we could really use your
support at joinpackman.com you'll get
access to the daily bonus show it's an
extra show every day for our members
when you sign up at joinpacman.com
all right well uh congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez
has covered and just days after her
florida trip during which republicans
complained about
her not wearing a mask outdoors and
about her
partner's feet being exposed in
flip-flops and about her supposedly
fleeing liberal new york to conservative
paradise florida so there's a bunch of
different stories here that i want to
talk about and mostly it's about the
reaction from these people so axios
report aoc test positive four covid
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
has tested positive her office confirmed
sunday evening
they're saying she's experiencing
symptoms and recovering at home the
congresswoman received her booster shot
this fall encourages everyone to get
their booster and follow all cdc
guidelines also a report from pix11 in
new york aoc positive for covid
it wasn't immediately clear what her
symptoms were or how severe
and that's really the only additional
information we have now marjorie taylor
green very quickly took to twitter oh no
not twitter where was this this must
have been on uh
this must be on some right wing thing
maybe this is parlor i don't know where
she said so because marjorie taylor
green's banned from twitter margaery
says super jabbed and vaxxed aoc has
coveted what was that from all the
unvaccinated republican men she said
wanted to date her really it's because
covet vaccines don't actually stop
anyone from getting sick with covid now
that's untrue as many of you know three
doses is 75 effective at preventing
symptomatic infection with omicron and
the overwhelming
decrease in hospitalization and death
from the vaccine continues to be obvious
if you look at the numbers marjorie
taylor green whoop
also saying aoc caught the pandemic of
the unvaccinated even though she is
totally triple vaxxed she shouldn't take
that horse medicine ivermectin and
monoclonal antibodies are for people who
meet certain criteria like obesity and
over 55 and that's not her so a lot of
very strange gloating from marjory
taylor green but there's a couple of
different things here to talk about
here's a clip from this morning on cnbc
of andrew rossorkin and becky quick
talking about it in the meantime new
york representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez has tested positive for
covid19 her office released a statement
yesterday saying that she is
experiencing symptoms and recovering at
home
the statement also said that the
congresswoman received a booster shot
last fall but andrew over the holidays
there were lots of pictures of her
unmasked out and about in florida and
she was already picking up heat for the
fact that it was kind of she was saying
people shouldn't be doing these things
but she was pictured doing a lot of
these things in florida so i think this
will be additional fodder for anybody
who's looking to take shots at her
you know
it's funny it's funny whether whether
getting covered now and i wonder whether
it's changed whether getting coveted is
a scarlet letter i would think not i
would think there was there was a point
early on it's not a start people thought
okay so so
there's there's a bunch of different
things here
first of all
um
these people now gloating
are the ones who haven't been following
the guidelines all along whose rates of
covid are far higher in red states than
blue states in trump counties versus
biden counties whose death rates are
higher whose hospitalization rates are
higher so why would they be mad at aoc
now well because of hypocrisy that would
be the explanation hypocrisy okay
did aoc violate any rules and the answer
is as far as i know she didn't uh she
wore a mask when traveling down to
florida
and she was outdoors and not wearing a
mask and okay so you could say well but
she's advocating for things to be rules
which then she ignores no she didn't
ignore any rules she wore the mask on
the plane okay whatever so what's the
lesson here
the lesson is this is so insanely
contagious
and these right wingers have continued
to say all of this stuff is bs
leave liberal new york and come to safe
florida where desantis is doing
everything great and it's so safe and
we're doing great on covid well
hospitalizations in florida are up 200
plus percent since the start of this
omicron wave but aoc went to florida and
she got covened so clearly it must not
be that safe now we're assuming that the
covid is a result of her having been in
florida if you think about the timing
she was in florida over the new year in
into into the new year and then she came
back and most people have two to three
days asymptomatic then symptoms start
sometimes it takes another day two or
three before you even show up as
positive and then you know we got the
sunday night which was was the ninth
we're presuming that this was the result
of being in florida it it may not even
be we we really don't know but it
doesn't matter um the the the idea here
is
all of these
right wing it's
likely that it happened as a result of
that trip uh and all of these
right-wingers who say you got to come
down to florida it's actually safer here
it doesn't actually appear to be also
remember
that we know she has coveted because she
got tested
and recently the florida surgeon general
has been saying we got to do away with
this testing culture you know testing
testing all the time
she could have followed that
and never gotten a positive test and
just lived her life and exposed more
people and on and on and on but she's
not doing that she's actually going to
go to a quarantine so
without a doubt what aoc did is risky
right now like this is so contagious you
know when i flew back a few weeks ago
every the entire airport was just filled
with coughing people i don't know how i
didn't get it
uh but the people calling her out are
doing the exact same stuff so the moral
of the story
it really is that contagious
um and i'm gonna be doing very little
for a couple of weeks and i want the
peak to be over and hopefully we'll have
far better looking numbers uh in in a
few weeks um the the other thing just to
consider is
it could have been going to florida
when she's in the bronx or wherever you
know new york city has an insanely high
positivity rate right now she's meeting
constituents she's going to ribbon
cutting she's doing all that stuff she's
in harm's way because of her job with
without question and ultimately i don't
know that it even really matters where
she got it but that's the latest
republicans gloating about aoc catching
covid
i told you last week that after joe
biden's
absolutely brutal speech
about the january 6th riots on the
one-year anniversary going right after
donald trump for his role in inciting
those riots
trump was so triggered trump put out
four consecutive statements
bizarre grammar random capitalization
each statement basically just a
repetition of the previous really really
strange stuff
well after that donald trump was
interviewed by oan
oan is the even more radical right-wing
network to newsmax which is already a
more radical right-wing version of fox
news which is crazy so imagine where
newsmax is newsmax went down to florida
it's relevant that this took place in
florida and you'll see why in a moment
and donald trump just can't even string
together a single coherent argument i
mean this is arguably the easiest
interview in history the interviewer was
getting autographs from trump either
before or after the interview she was
pictured this is like a fan of trump's
just letting him do whatever he wants
and it's still humiliating and trump is
still saying
any second now states are going to be
turned over to him he's talking about
the 2020 election i i know you're saying
it's david sir it's 2022.
trump is talking about flipping states
in the 2020 election we ran a third
world election
and things are coming out over the next
couple of days maybe even today we're
always days away from the blockbuster
one case i hear a very big story is
coming out today
on the cheating
and
numerous states are going to be
turned i don't know what they're going
to do but it's going to show that they
were won by me
it's already shown right if you look at
if you look at arizona if you look at
the findings in arizona is it sad at
this point guys
that it's still the same talking points
that's over right we want it
and i'm gonna go out there next week
we're making a speech but if you look at
those findings
we won the state so trump did not win
arizona now then
trump goes back to talking about the
size of his pathetic
crowd
he again is talking about crowd size i i
know it's 20 22. everything was going
beautifully and then the election got
rigged
and stolen
from the american people and by the way
that's the reason they went in massive
numbers they don't cover the numbers of
people they always show the capital with
a very small just a tiny percentage of
the people that were there right they
never show helicopter
pictures of that incredible crowd
because it was the largest crowd i've
ever spoken before
i i believe he's talking about the
january 6th crowd never had a crowd i've
never seen a crowd that big
he's never even read oh right he doesn't
read so okay then it was massive it was
the real number i won't say imagine the
interview it was it was massive it was
massive because it'll be a headline oh
he exaggerated the number the real
number
was over that sacred number okay you
know what that number was right i do and
sacred i i don't even talk about that
it's kind of talking about it right now
then trump very strangely started saying
the media is censoring pictures of how
big the crowd was i mean this is a very
sick individual but why do we have such
a dishonest press that's the question
and why don't they show the real crowd
right that was there on january 6th the
crowd of people that was the biggest
i've ever seen i haven't seen anybody
you can hardly get a picture we're
trying to find pictures
they have they have censored to pick the
pictures
they don't want to show that crowd it's
all been completely it's you you can't
go to google images and type in trump
january 6 cr
oh you can oh
oh you get thousands of results oh sorry
the pictures are censored now one nice
moment
nice
is when trump continues to go after
mitch mcconnell and mike pence for the
election loss this is really great news
because it shows us the continued divide
within the party which is what the left
has the left is doing so poorly at
putting together a good strategy for 22
we have to hope that their own division
will hurt them trump going right after
mcconnell and pence here take a look
what do you think uh
what does the american public need to do
in order to
not just feel secure but actually secure
our elections well we have to get better
people than mitch mcconnell who
immediately gave up
and you know mike pence was it was sad
because when you have more votes and you
have voters you could send that back
to the legislatures right right send it
back hey excuse me we have more votes
and runs would you check it out
and by that time they would have done
something because as you know they were
starting to get angry around that time
they said wait a minute we've been
scammed they're a protester so that was
disappointing with mike and mitch
mcconnell
shouldn't have accepted it isn't that
the best how
it is not common that a president so
consistently
criticizes his own vice president and
said mike failed us it was really
disappointing mike pence couldn't have
done anything and mike pence was right
he knew it
then the topic came up of what actually
happened on january 6th and trump talked
about
uh all of the love
that day take a look at this this is
wild and it was cold that day people
people were very cold and weren't it was
love that day there was so much love out
there during the speech
but a tiny percentage and they started
walking to the capitol
in many cases before i even spoke right
it couldn't it it was their idea it
wasn't even anything trump did you know
that was well known yeah but um
they should show helicopter shots right
of the crowd not taken six hours before
like they did with my inauguration
you know were they still talking about
the crowd size in 2017 guys you know the
inauguration hours before
and they talk about oh not that many
people because i tell you what it went
down to the washington monument and they
know it
just like they showed the empty
basketball arena
and they basketball the guy is still
talking about the crowd size now the
interview is completely unhinged what
we're expecting at the rally in arizona
on saturday is probably more of this
this is a very very sick man
but one of the really funny things is
when trump was president the faa
wouldn't allow planes to fly over
mar-a-lago you know mar-a-lago down in
florida there it's near so many
different airports in the flight paths
that's not happening anymore and
multiple times i just love this multiple
times during the interview you hear
planes right overhead and you can see
you can see and hear in trump's voice
that he gets annoyed by it it is
constant now check this out but people
respected us and they weren't going to
mess around you know when you're weak
you end up in wars
and
we were respected so one year ago
we were respected like probably never
before one year ago we were respected
now he can't even get the planes to stop
flying over muralago it happens again
later in the interview and again it just
sort of seems to slightly distract trump
you know his ego is very bruised that
now planes are making noise over his
house all day you do and what oan does
is so important
and you have a much bigger audience than
people understand thank you but you
cover it better than anybody and
we're talking about elections that are
broken rigged
and you've been saying this you were
saying this all right so you guys get it
just just another one of these insane
interviews and uh
do not be confused
this will continue trump will continue
uh meddling in or you know metal
depending on your perspective meddling
or being involved in uh republican
politics
until the republican party doesn't allow
him anymore
or until his health goes bad and he's
not able to anymore but he seems as
determined as ever to be involved so a
humiliating oan interview there's going
to be more of this coming make sure
you're following us on instagram at
david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
right this you really have to see to
believe i'm going to play video for you
today
of really a servant serving his master
that's really what this is and the
servant is a sitting u.s senator and the
master is a fox news propagandist i'm
talking about ted cruz and tucker
carlson if you haven't been following
the story
it is really incredible what this says
about the current state of political
affairs the current state of society and
the republican party
um
wednesday last wednesday uh we were you
know it was the the anniversary of uh
january we were it was the eve of the
anniversary of january 6th and in a
senate hearing ted cruz said
we were approaching the anniversary of a
violent terrorist attack on the capitol
and
a lot of people on the right
didn't like ted cruz calling what
happened on january 6 2021 a terrorist
attack
and tucker carlson didn't like it and
apparently
tucker carlson and ted cruz started
texting about it
and ted cruz ended up appearing on the
tucker carlson program
to apologize i am going to play for you
a sitting u.s senator having to go on
and do a maya culpa to the person who is
really in charge apparently tucker
carlson and this shouldn't surprise us
hannity was giving trump advice and in
contact with trump telling him what to
do
um what does it say what does it say
when a republican senator answers to a
right-wing media propagandist let's take
a look at this so we played this tape
for you last time we were surprised by
it we prefaced it by saying every
conservative appreciates ted cruz
because he's one of the smartest and
most articulate people in the congress
and he's conservative
but he referred publicly to what
happened on january 6th is quote a
violent terror attack here it is
we are approaching a solemn anniversary
this week
and it is an anniversary of a violent
terrorist attack on the capitol where we
saw the men and women of law enforcement
demonstrate incredible courage
incredible bravery
risk their lives
to defend the men and women who serve in
this capital
really not controversial now many will
focus on none of them were charged with
terrorism it's very common that people
aren't charged with literally the thing
that we colloquially say they did
there's still a debate is it or isn't it
terrorism but this it's really not a big
deal what he said and look at tucker's
concerned face and ted cruz has been a
bad boy and he's gonna have to apologize
senator cruz was game enough to come on
tonight we appreciate that he joins us
now senator thanks so much for coming on
so i guess what i mean there are a lot
of dumb people in the congress you're
not one of them i think you're smarter
than i am uh and you never use words
carelessly um and yet you called this a
terror attack
when by no definition was it a terror
attack that's a lie
you told that lie on purpose and i'm
wondering why you did
well tucker thank you for having me on
when you aired your episode last night i
i sent you a text shortly thereafter and
said listen i'd like to go on because
sir i'd like to apologize pretty please
the way i phrased things yesterday it it
was sloppy and and it was frankly dumb
yeah i don't buy that whoa whoa whoa
whoa i don't buy that for look i'm the
teacher that's not a good enough apology
little ted the teacher's going to demand
a better apology on you a long time
since before you went to the senate
you're a supreme court contender you
take words as seriously as any man who's
ever served in the senate and every word
you repeated that phrase i by the way
imagine ted cruz on the supreme court
that's a horror movie do not believe
that you use that accidentally i just
don't it's so tucker as a result of my
sloppy phrasing it's caused a lot of
people to misunderstand what i meant let
me tell you what what i meant to say
what i was referring to are are the
limited number of people who engaged in
violent attacks against police officers
i think you and i both agree that if you
assault a police officer you should go
to jail that's who i was talking about
and the reason the phrasing was sloppy
is i have talked dozens if not hundreds
of times i've drawn a distinction i
wasn't saying that the thousand this is
so pathetic if you watch this and you go
who has the power here
is it the us senator or is it the fox
propagandist
it's obviously the fox propagandist the
peaceful protesters supporting donald
trump are somehow terrorists i wasn't
saying the millions of of patriots
across the country supporting president
trump are terrorists and that's what a
lot of people have misunderstood that
wait a second even your way but hold on
what you just said doesn't make sense so
if somebody assaults a cop he should be
charged and go to jail i couldn't agree
more we have said that for years
but that person's still not a terrorist
how many people have been charged with
terrorism on january 6th like why'd you
use that word you're playing into the
other side's
characterization that is joe kent ted
cruz has been a bad bad boy just
explained allows them to define an
entire population as foreign combatants
and you know that so why'd you do it so
tucker let me answer you directly the
reason i use that word for a decade
i have referred to people who violently
assault police officers as terrorists
i've done so over and over and over
again if you look at all the assaults
we've seen across the country i've
called that terrorism over and over
again that being said tucker i agree
with you it was a mistake to say that
yesterday i know what you just said
i've been bad i've apologized three
times already please we've now had a
year of democrats in the media twisting
words right and trying to say that all
of us are terrorists trying to say
you're a terrorist i'm a terrorist and
so look i don't talk about a red herring
huh like people who who assault cops and
and i
stand up and defend cops
and
the reason i use that word is that's the
word i've always used for people that
violently attack cops but in this
context i get why people were angry
because we've had a year of the corrupt
corporate media and democrats claiming
anyone who
objected to to the election fraud and by
the way remember what was happening
can i just ask hold on you work in this
i just i guess i just don't believe you
and i mean that with respect because i
have such respect
for your you're so great that this is
too stupid for me to accept acuity and
your precision and i've seen it on
display i've covered you as a reporter i
know how you speak
and you have sat there for a year and
watched people use language to distort
the event anyway it goes on from here
you can find the entire thing online
what does it say about society that ted
cruz answers to the right-wing media
propagandist of the day
obviously our elected officials should
answer to us the people we're the ones
who elect them that's not what's going
on here ted cruz is not uh tucker
carlson is not a constituent of ted cruz
this is really an indication of the
power dynamics and ted cruz sort of gets
to use the term colloquially ted cruz
gets cucked by everybody because
remember trump
called ted cruz's wife ugly
and then ted cruz came out and said
trump's great i support trump i love
trump trump trump trump and then now
here he is doing his may could i have
some more porridge please
uh totally subservient totally
subservient to tucker carlson really
interesting uh uh instructive example of
who is actually holding the power in
these dynamics right now hey i want to
briefly tell you
about the fact that one of the accused
trump rioters was out on bail and killed
a young mother in a drunk driving crash
now why is this story of particular
importance why would i highlight this
story
for six years trumpists have been
talking about undocumented immigrants
out on bail in the country are
committing this crime and that crime and
these are just terrible terrible people
imagine if the situation here was
reversed and some left-wing
blm protester out on bail killed someone
in a drunk driving accident what would
be happening on fox news right now but a
version of that is what happened here
emily hernandez infamously appeared in
photos carrying a broken sign
from the house speaker nancy pelosi's
office
this was a trump writer
there's it's beyond beyond question 22
year old woman
oh boy all of a sudden i'm having a
problem reading this article i guess i
need a daily beast subscription which i
don't have okay 22 year old woman
trump rioter out on bail drunk driving
kills the uh a young mother
and i want to go through the numerous
hypocrisies here
for decades
the right hasn't cared about conditions
in jails or prisons if you're there you
must have done something wrong you
deserve it we don't coddle people we
aren't norway with nice jails
now it's trumpists because some of them
because of their role in the january 6
riots
and they are saying they're being
treated terribly
the prison and jail conditions are
terrible the vegan guy is not getting
his vegan food since when do you care
about conditions in prisons and jails
these trumpists they can't mount good
defenses if they are stuck in pre-trial
detention all the way up until their
trial right we've been saying that about
all sorts of offenders including
relatively low-level drug offenders held
without bail unable to mount a proper
defense and you didn't care
now you care because it's trumpists and
then it's we can't let illegals out on
bail
then they go and commit crimes even
though we know undocumented immigrants
commit crime at a lower rate than
natural born american citizens and then
here we go here's a trump rioter out on
bail gets drunk and kills someone
driving around in a car
the reality is
either you're a danger and you need to
be in custody or you're not and you
should be out until you appear in court
or have to report to prison or whatever
the case may be
this doesn't have to take on the
political nature the reason we are
pointing out the political nature is
number one because these are issues that
the right has first ignored and now all
of a sudden they care about whereas we
on the left have cared about these
important issues for a really long time
pre-trial detention bail
et cetera uh and number two
um because they
only are paying attention when it
affects one side these people truly are
pathetic
and they're silent on this particular
issue just imagine if this was a blm
protester or someone from antifa
uh what you would be seeing on
right-wing media right now let's take a
quick break we'll be back right after
this much more to cover today
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com david pakman show so
after covering a couple of notable
anti-vaccine covet deaths last week many
of you over the weekend sent me all
sorts of other examples of this and
there's a couple i want to highlight and
i highlight these not to point the
finger and laugh at people i don't find
that there's anything to laugh at but to
show all of the different ways in which
this toxic delusional thinking infects
people
and then they end up in horrible
situations their families end up in
horrible situations and it's absolutely
horrifying an anti-vaccine podcaster who
got covered at a conspiracy con
conference
during which coveted conspiracies were
spread
has now died of covet i'm talking about
61 year old doug
kuzma
a q anon and anti-vaxx podcaster has
died from complications due to covid
after getting the virus at a conspiracy
theory conference which became a super
spreader event where attendees blamed
their illness on an anthrax attack i
don't know if you remember that
last week or maybe maybe it was the week
before i told you about this conspiracy
conference
where tons of people got covered and
they said we believe we were targeted
with anthrax and of course you apply a
simple kind of colloquial occam's razor
what's more likely that anthrax which is
difficult to get in the u.s really more
prevalent in other parts of the world
and uh it is what's responsible as a
targeted attack against us when the
symptoms are the one of the virus that's
rapidly spreading everywhere why would
we choose the anthrax over the cove well
didn't make any sense this guy has now
died not from anthrax but from covid
doug kuzma 61 year old from newport news
virginia died after being hospitalized
10 days earlier kuzma broadcasted on the
frog news podcasting network which
stands for fully rely on god kuzma and
his fellow hosts pushed an array of
conspiracy theories ranging from q anon
to covid denial and election fraud lies
kuzma attended the reawaken america
conference in dallas on the weekend of
december 11th posting a picture of his
media pass
other images posted show large crowds
and confined spaces with no social
distancing or masks i literally told you
guys when we would look at clips from
reawaken america
these are
coveted hellscapes
and now he has died
the conspiracy-laden event organized by
tulsa businessman clay clark was
headlined by people like the disgraced
former national security adviser michael
flynn conspiracy theorist alex jones and
eric trump several unvaccinated
conspiracy theorists and fraud promoters
basically claimed they were targeted
with anthrax kuzma reported he was
feeling ill claimed it was chronic
bronchitis flaring up again
from the picture he looks obese and
chronic bronchitis and you don't get a
vaccine and when coveted is rampantly
spreading you go to a conference with
tons of other unvaccinated and unmasked
people
it's really unbelievable
some
on december 15th
he posted that he had a fever someone
commented he should get a covet test and
he said no way
he was told better safe than sorry and
he lashed out saying you must have lost
your mind so they can kill me and try to
give me the jab i'll die at the house
before i go to the hospital well after
suffering for fever for five days
he was forced to admit he probably had
coveted he was found unconscious at his
house on christmas eve and rushed to the
hospital
he was not responding to treatment he
was sedated and placed on a ventilator
according to a fellow member the final
message kuzma sent was a photo of
himself
uh with a refill of ivor mektin
oh my god
um
his daughter stopped sharing posts
about his condition because she was
against his truth or movement he pushed
anti-vaxx conspiracies
they also provo promote multi-level
marketing company life wave on the frog
network
which sells wearable patches that
promise to activate your stem cells and
reset them to a younger healthier state
um
man you know it this is instructive in
so many ways
the mlm stuff he was pushing
it didn't help him survive the
ivermectin didn't help him
uh he didn't get the vaccine and you
know candace owens recently said she'll
die before getting the vaccine
that is clearly that there are people
choosing that
there are people choosing that and this
is sad
this is not something i look at and i
laugh at and we have another example to
look at next example
the q anon star kirsten weldon
who said only idiots get vaccinated
is dead of covet
it's we're now getting multiple ones a
day
kirsten weldon told her fans
not to get vaccinated
wanted dr fauci killed
she believed he should be executed
she is dead of covet
a leading q anon promoter who urged both
her followers and strangers she passed
on the street not to get vaccinated died
thursday of the virus
she amassed tens of thousands of
followers on right wing media by by
promoting the pro-trump q anon
conspiracy under the name kirsten w
um weldon focused on attacking vaccines
and other efforts to fight covid saying
in one video that dr anthony fauci needs
to be hung from a rope she claimed the
vaccine killed people
and even recorded herself yelling at
people standing in line to get
vaccinated the vaccines killed don't get
it this is how gullible these idiots are
they're all getting the vaccine
in december weldon started showing
symptoms of the virus
on december 28th weldon struggled
through remarks about the coming
overthrow of the government coughing and
saying she was exhausted three days
later she found herself in a hospital
posted a picture wearing an oxygen mask
claiming she had bacterial pneumonia
she wrote she refused to take
coronavirus treatment from desevere
calling it dr fauci's res-medervir
misspelling it
this is the latest instance of a
far-right personality who opposed
vaccination killed by the virus i just
told you about doug kuzma who also died
in the same way we've previously talked
about robert david steele
um
we talked about veronica wallski a q
anon follower who was hospitalized with
the virus people started calling in
saying give her ivermectin she died
later that month
um
what is there to say at this point i
mean do we have sympathy my audience is
mixed on this i whenever i do a story
like this some of you write to me and
you say i have no sympathy they didn't
get vaccinated etc
they are perpetrators they are also
victims
i mean
if you fall for this stuff
in some way you are a victim of
disinformation it's it's a it's an
empirical reality you've fallen for
misinformation
you didn't create it you've fallen for
it
and at the same time you are a
perpetrator because you encourage others
to do the same and who knows how many
people got sick as a result
of either of these individuals so i know
my audience is mixed on this
but at this point in time
given the level of contagion of omicron
and how easily it spreads
the vaccine is increasingly to protect
yourself
would these individuals have survived if
they had had three doses statistically
it's likely
you you know you can't draw a conclusion
about an individual doug kuzma with his
uh
bronchial condition
and the weight
he might have died either way we don't
know
statistically
he would have had a dramatically reduced
shot at dying if he had had three doses
of course same same with the with
kirsten weldon here as well
um so i continue to welcome your
thoughts about
what should be our view about things
like this
uh but get yourselves vaccinated my my
family lost an additional person over
the weekend
my uh my dad's cousin in argentina
um
vaccinated
initially down there they had the
russian and chinese vaccines i don't
know exactly which one he had but
vaccinated to some degree
had pre-existing conditions
came down with the virus unclear where
he got it
ended up being sedated on a ventilator
for three weeks developed infections
developed kidney issues horrible
horrible horrible devastating
uh to the family and he died over the
weekend
um
and uh if you have an opportunity to get
vaccinated take it because that's the
fate of afflicting
disproportionately unvaccinated people
my dad's cousin had pre-existing
conditions there's no doubt about it uh
but he was not particularly old
and it got him why
why not wear the suit of armor if you're
walking through the forest
of arrows why not wear the seat belt if
you're driving you might never need it
but you might
uh and i i am convinced we are going to
see more and more stories like this
continue to come in
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p um we we were talking
about racism at the workplace last week
and the eggman called in i guess the egg
man mostly works with racist people and
here are his observations which i find
pretty interesting hi dave i was really
interested in you discussing how very
racist people handle their jobs at work
i just want to say that i work in a
company that has mostly racist people
okay and i will give you my deduction on
that okay the more racist they are the
nicer they are to the black people and
minorities inside the shop behind the
back n-word n-word all day long but when
the black african-american people or
puerto rican hispanics show up they are
the friendliest to them my wife thinks
it's because they're scared of them okay
i'm not extra friendly to black people
i'm not extra mean to black people i'm
just normal to everybody but um racist
people in in the po in public in jobs
they hide it very well because in their
minds they're afraid of other races so
they act extra sweet it really irritates
me
i see them being nice to these black
people and minorities that i work with
and i know they just used the word
as with me before and now they act all
buddy buddy i think it's totally
disgusting shalom brother oh also in the
printing industry most people are racist
and it has nothing to do with their job
because they do a great job and they're
thinking the n-word all day long wow i
didn't realize the printing industry was
so plagued with with racism that's very
interesting you know i did um
growing up
gargoyle i mean you know late teens
early 20s
i had uh someone in my circles who was
quite racist privately
and they were insanely polite whenever
there were black or or what i would call
notably hispanic people around as many
of you know i'm hispanic by most
definitions but
when i'm saying brown people when there
were black and brown people around this
racist person in my in my circle who was
not part of it anymore it was not my
friend um
they they were notably polite to
minorities and the eggman's theory or
hypothesis is it's because they're
scared they don't want to get hurt by
the minorities so they they become extra
polite
interesting insights from the eggman we
have a really great bonus show for you
today we are going to talk about the sad
news of comedian and full house star an
all-around good guy from what i know bob
saget dead at 65 found dead in a hotel
room you won't be shocked that it is
leading to coveted conspiracies coveted
vaccine conspiracies but we'll talk
about what is actually known about it
the james webb space telescope is fully
deployed great so it's all set right
no now it's five months of configuration
and adjustments and calibration but
we'll tell you what's going on it's
super interesting and uh this is just
insane new york mayor eric adams has
been in the job for a few days
he has appointed his brother to a hun a
240 000 job that from what i've looked
at his brother is not qualified for
we'll dig into that in more detail but
that's my early assessment not qualified
for the job
how do you get access to the bonus show
very easy sign up on my website
joinpakman.com we have a membership
program we are fully demonetized on
facebook for the next 90 days so we
really need your help uh please sign up
at joinpackman.com and we will see you
on today's bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman